Hey,
what's going on as bill burn?
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcasting.
Just checking in on you.
Um,
just chicken on Anya.
How are you?
Come in the middle of a tour.
I'm in Charleston.
South Carolina is fucking places.
Amazing.
I was just telling somebody about how beautiful it is here.
Everybody always goes to Savannah,
Georgia.
You don't want to go to Savannah,
Savannah,
Georgia is like the Times Square of the south light.
Everybody knows about.
It's everybody's gonna fucking end up there.
And then what happens?
Yeah,
everybody sits around going,
why the fuck didn't we just stay in Atlanta?
In fact,
that's the number one thing said in Savannah,
Georgia.
So everybody's all about that.
Okay.
Savannah,
Georgia is the VHS
of quaint southern cities.
Alright.
Charleston,
South Carolina.
That's the Beta.
That's the shit.
Yeah.
That they should have used,
but they didn't cause everybody always gravitates towards,
you know,
the more mainstream what,
so whatever.
They're both beautiful,
but I love this,
this fucking place.
I'm telling you,
we get down near the water.
It literally,
it looks like a Tom Hanks movie.
You know,
like Tom Hanks,
we'll be walking down the street with Meg Ryan,
you know,
and all the soccer moms would be like,
they just look good together.
Um,
speaking of Tom Hanks,
did anybody see that movie?
Sally.
Sally,
Shelly,
but going into the water,
Joe,
what the fuck?
Um,
I haven't seen it yet.
I'm hoping.
Well,
Clint Eastwood did it right,
so probably would be good.
I was just nervous.
Said it was just going to be a bunch of,
uh,
you know,
there's only one place to land this thing that's going to be in the water.
Yeah.
Like they were going to do some overdramatic fucking uh,
Hollywood shit,
but it's clean.
He split.
So maybe they did.
I just think it's funny that it's named Sally and he's not from fucking,
I don't even know where he's from.
I just looked at his last name.
It's like,
that's not Sullivan.
Why they call him him?
Sally.
Sally is short for Sullivan and this other guy,
I don't know what his name is,
just like seller when a,
when a witness or something,
you know,
so they just go by celly.
I think it's a Polish name.
I don't know what the fuck it is.
All I know is Tom Hanks let his hair go white.
Right?
Is that a weird fucking thing?
Just dying your hair
like I don't understand why people do that.
Why didn't you allow to look old?
Like if you're like a 60 year old,
like there'll be people in movies in that play in like a 60 year old guy and
they have like jet black hair.
What could shoe pels tough like fucking shoe leather.
That Guy Damn Shoe Polish.
Yeah.
Everybody should just let themselves go to shit and Hollywood
would be great.
That would,
you still need the hottest but I'm just saying once you get past a certain age,
like 40 they should just let you go to shit,
you know?
And that would be great.
It's always fun to see some double Chin fucking baldy walking around,
right?
Or do you guys need them to all look good?
I have no fucking idea how it works.
All I know is the guy's last name isn't Sullivan goes by the name Sally.
A couple of fucking birds or something went into the jet engine.
He had to set that thing down in the fucking Hudson River.
All right.
God,
I can't imagine that.
Hey,
so I was flying down to South Carolina.
Uh,
that's all I have to say about that.
You know,
that unbelievable event.
I just say,
my God,
I can't imagine that.
All right,
next subject.
So I was flying down to South Carolina this morning and a fucking Bill Murray
was on my flight.
How cool is that?
Huh?
Big Urn McCracken.
Okay.
The guy from stripes,
caddy shack and all those fucking legendary movies.
So now I'm trying to think of the amount of people from the original error of
SNL.
I know he wasn't one of the original ones.
I've,
uh,
I did a movie with Jane Curtin and then at the party,
the Christmas party of the director,
I met Ray Laraine Newman.
So that's two.
And then I saw Bill Murray.
John Belushi's gone,
never saw Dan Akroyd Chevy chase.
I was at his roast.
So I got like three out of six Garrett Morris.
I met him.
It's not bad.
Fucking going right to the cast.
Bill Murray was on a flight,
you know.
Yeah.
I was fucking,
while walking down the street and uh,
Hal Mcrae,
Pete was on the sand and went the fuck,
you know,
this is why I can't,
I can't do these fucking podcasts when I'm on the road.
I got like three hours sleep last night and it wasn't because I was boozing.
I did two amazing shows at the paramount theater out in Long Island,
one of the most beautiful places I've ever performed out with some of the
sickest goddamn food.
And I ate eating perfectly the whole night because I was working with Vinny
mark.
And we got this tradition where whenever we worked with each other,
we always end up going to white castle.
So I'm like,
I'm going to eat fucking perfectly.
And
I woke up or did I have and I didn't have shit.
Right.
And when I did the opiod,
Jimmy show had a great time.
Yeah.
And then I went down to the village.
That's right to do Lenny Marcus's and fucking Kevin Brennon's podcasts at the
comedy cellar.
And they had,
they have an oatmeal place.
Just,
I never order oatmeal publicly.
I never do it cause it always tastes like paste and they fuck it up at that
place.
All they do is oatmeal or they call themselves oatmeal's.
So they're ended the shit.
So I went in there and I got a bowl of that.
So that was good.
Right?
Then you guys got to listen to this podcast by the way.
You know,
it's funny,
there was so much screaming and yelling on this,
just done by one man.
By the way,
Kevin Brennan just out of his fucking tree screaming at me.
If you ever want to listen to somebody just screamed at me,
you know,
and be mad that I'm selling tickets.
This is,
this is,
this is the show.
You have to fucking listen to it.
Let me find out the name here.
Lenny Marcus
podcast.
All right,
here we go.
What is it called?
Something
misery loves company.
Okay.
All right.
It's him and Kevin Brennan and I,
Jesus Christ.
Kevin Brennan was going off on me,
but uh,
I got some good digs in on him at one point.
He was so fucking over the top screaming that me and Lenny would just sort of
singing underneath him like happy songs to try to take the edge off of what he
was saying.
Um,
but
we will have in fun.
But,
uh,
I don't know when that fucking thing's coming out,
but uh,
to give you an example,
he was like,
oh,
what do you,
what you do?
Oh,
I'm fucking Billpro I just get on stage and I fucking scream and then I get to
play these big venues.
He was just trashing me the entire fucking time.
And,
um,
I got to admit,
you know,
at 11 in the morning was a little bit much,
but,
uh,
came out of it unscathed,
so I knew I didn't have enough time to do fucking cardio.
You know what it really is,
is a gym near where I was staying in New York.
And,
um,
they always ask for your fucking driver's license when you go in there.
It's like,
I'll just pay with my credit card.
And they're like,
we have to make a copy of your driver's license.
It's like,
for what?
You're not the feds,
what do you,
I know,
what the fuck are you using that force?
You get my name and my address and then you sell that information.
There's such fucking assholes.
So instead of going to the gym,
I just walked from the village all the way to the upper west side.
It wasn't even that bad a walk.
It's just a slow fucking inclined.
I'm a big La Pussy anyway,
so I'm always fucking going on hikes.
So it wasn't even that bad.
And
I forgot about like how difficult it is to walk through New York City sometimes
and,
and there's two different,
there's three,
three groups of people that fucking drive me nuts.
The first two are obvious.
The Group of seven people who are walking seven abreast,
so they can all hear each other,
you know,
like that they're walking up the street like not even like reservoir dogs where
they had a little bit of daylight.
We can pick your holes like Oj Simpson,
right.
Cut back against the grain.
They're like fucking,
you know,
like a bunch of cops trying to break up a protest,
right?
Arm's locked.
There's those people,
there's the group of people that walks out of like a hotel or they just got done
eating and they all stand in the middle of the sidewalk looking up at buildings
and trying to figure out what the fuck they're going to do.
And then one of the most frustrating ones ever is the person walking in front of
you who was walking slightly diagonal and they always walking the diagonal that
you,
you're trying to fucking pass them on and then you cut to the other side.
They liked it.
It's like they're drunk or they're texting while walking.
I don't know what the fuck it is,
but those are the people,
you know,
you want to come up behind them,
give him the old slew foot there.
Um,
but anyways,
let me get to the,
uh,
get to the long island shows here.
Um,
you know,
I'm getting ready to do this special and um,
I had a Vinnie mark open and for me,
we're having a great time talking about the old days and he just was really just
such a fucking nice guy to me.
I guess I was telling you when I first,
when I first started out and,
um,
but he knows all like the long island stand up history cause he was a part of it
and he was saying right down the street and I always heard about this place was
the east side comedy club.
And um,
this was this place out in,
uh,
out in Long Island.
We like fucking everybody got their start.
MMM.
Eddie Murphy,
Ray Romano,
Kevin James,
Rosie O'Donnell,
Paul Riser,
Jim Carey,
this guy,
Ritchie men.
I'm going to say his fucking name wrong.
I can't read.
I'm intervening.
MMM.
Uh,
fuck was was the article.
This is the wrong God damn article here.
Yeah.
All right.
I'll just read you this article.
It says Richard [inaudible],
he should've worked for NASA because he helped launched the careers of so many
big name New York comics in this,
the ones I just mentioned,
right.
And uh,
Eddie Murphy,
Ray Romano,
Kevin James,
Rosie O'Donnell,
Paul Riser,
Jim Carey,
a director,
Judd Apatow.
Lot of people didn't know why he started doing standup again,
but he did that before.
You know,
he did stand up initially before he did the 40 year old virgin knocked up and
all those huge movies and now he's back to doing stand up while also making all
these great movies.
So anyways,
all of their comedy bones made their comedy bones in the 1980s and nineties in
Huntington Long Island at the legendary east side comedy club,
which closed in 1995.
Um,
Richie said I was in real estate in 1979 but I wanted to be a comedian,
a top comic who plays all the a list casinos and works the cruise ships circuit.
That was pretty much as high up as anybody got back then.
Um,
he goes,
I got sick of driving into the city trying to get on stage at the Improv or
catch a rising star.
So I found this restaurant in Huntington and made it into a comedy club.
Jackie Mason headlined his grand opening.
Jackie asked how I was going to pay him.
10 grand is 10 fee with an $8 cover for 135 seats.
Richie said,
I have no idea what I was doing a so I said,
I don't know.
And then Jackie was cool and said he told me to pay them next year,
which I did his first regular night of stand up.
Listen to this as first fucking show.
We have a booked at this club.
This is a legendary east side comedy club with this was to show Eddie Murphy
right there over legendary show.
Jerry Seinfeld,
Jackie the joke man,
Marlin Paul Riser,
Rob Bartlett,
Bob Nelson in himself.
Each person did eight minutes and he said,
I never dreamed that most of those guys would go on to become a big time
superstars.
And then he had all these great stories that vividly remembers Eddie Murphy
shoes.
Said just before he went on stage,
Eddie would take a brand new pair of shoes out of the box,
wear them on stage.
It was a different pair every night.
Finally I found out he worked in a shoe store and he'd put them back on the
shelf.
The next day.
I fucking hilarious is that he said Ray Romano,
or go on stage wearing a snazzy blazer blazer.
He'd take it off,
hang it on the chair.
So he would just walk out wearing it,
eat hanging on the chair.
He do his act,
then carry his jacket off stage and then you'd see the price tag on the inside
raid,
return it the next day for a refund.
Um,
this guy Rick,
he,
he told Richie told Jerry Seinfeld that he was hilarious but he needed to be
more dirty.
And Joey was like,
yeah,
but then when I do the tonight show,
I'll have to clean it up and it'll hurt my time.
And he said,
Richie just smirked and said,
sure,
Jerry.
Sure.
Like,
like,
you know,
you're actually going to get on the tonight show,
which of course he did.
Um,
and he just had a bunch of kind of things to say about Kevin James and all those
guys say they haven't changed at all,
but,
um,
what's his face?
Took me down the street and show me like the location where the first thing was.
And I'm like,
I'm such a fucking nerd.
For the past,
you know,
especially if it's something that I'm into,
when I would go to do,
you know what drives me up the fucking wall.
When you go to do the opion Jimmy show,
they got this,
this space age elevator system where you don't just hit the button,
you got to hit what floor you're on.
So the whole concept is that like,
all right,
you know,
cause people have to get to work fast as like 40 fucking floors.
If we break them up into clusters like this,
these five floors,
they hair these fucking four over there.
In theory,
it always,
you know,
to add,
to make it more fucking difficult always seems like somehow it's going to make
it easier,
which it never does.
So you go there right now you've got to,
we to look on your,
your car,
don't remember what fucking floor you're going to,
you know.
So I went up and I was like,
God,
that wasn't bad.
That actually maybe made it faster.
And then when I go to leave the show,
I want to hit lobby and I'm hitting lobby and I'm hitting lobbying.
I'm hitting lobbying.
It's not fucking working.
You know why?
Cause I'm on like the top floor and that's the only one anybody hits when
they're up there.
So it's all fucking worn out.
Like some old like ATM thing and I'm just sitting there in a panic.
Like I got to go down to Lenny's fucking podcast.
I can't get the elevator,
you know,
just fucking hit the Arrow button.
I know I sound like a Goddamn [inaudible] but I swear to God like we should have
stopped with the fucking technology.
And I know this would affect the fact that I wouldn't be able to get to do this
podcast,
but I don't give a shit.
Somewhere in the mid nineties was the tipping point.
All right.
Now we can keep people alive too long.
We're just making everything fucking difficult.
Everything gets replaced and then you just,
you just throw it in the fucking ocean,
right?
I mean that's no good.
Is it okay.
Yeah.
He wouldn't think I'd be in,
in order to design.
I didn't get any fucking sleep.
So late last night we ended up going to a white castle
and I got two doubles and two chickens and a little bit of French fries or
whatever.
After eating well all day,
by the way,
the paramount theaters,
food is fucking sick.
If you're there,
you get the sliders and he's got these little tuna fucking cigar things.
They rolled them up on this little shell thing,
like a cigar Nitze sprinkled pepper on the answer.
It looks like a fucking cigar.
It's the shit.
Um,
I still think I eat pretty good,
but like the white castle obviously fucking killed me.
So Vinnie ends up driving me and he's telling me all these great stories about
the east side comedy club and all the people that he worked with.
So he drives me back in his city,
drops me off where I'm staying.
And as I,
as his car drives away,
I realized I left my cell phone in his car.
So I'm like,
fuck.
So I see this fucking dude sitting down
right
on the stoop.
So I'm like,
I fucking run,
you know,
next door said,
hey man,
my buddy just took off a car.
Can I just use your cell phone just so I can call,
you know,
and he's holding his cell phone so I can just call blah blah,
blah,
you know,
and get my phone back.
Could just let me make a real quick phone call.
And the guy just looks at me.
He just goes,
he's like looking up,
he's sitting on the first day and I'm looking down at him.
He just looks up and he just goes like,
yeah,
no,
no.
I'm just like,
really?
You fucking cunt,
right?
So just this little fucking Dweeb.
I should have just slapped the fucking phone right out and thrown in a puddle.
Um,
so I'm just not,
what a fucking Dixon and I run down,
there's a bar on the corner.
This is fucking dude,
all tattooed up,
neck tattoos,
the whole fucking thing.
I just talked to like the biggest pussy ever.
And he said,
no,
now I'm going to go up to this guy from like fucking this sons of anarchy.
I just say,
fuck it.
I go,
man,
you got,
can I just use yourself?
I told him the whole thing and he just goes,
yeah,
sure.
Let me fucking use it.
I called him and I was fine.
That little fucking pricks of standing there waiting for my buddy to come back.
I'm just staring at the guy and I just,
I hadn't actually be like,
I actually respected them on some level,
you know,
maybe just looked at me and I just looked like such a fucking Ron Howard looking
jackass that he had no respect for me.
What a fucking,
it's been a while since I just prayed for something like really bad to happen to
somebody.
No,
I like really bad.
I just mean like as ac breaks and nobody comes and fixes it.
He just sits there in the fucking heat wave.
MMM.
Anyways,
this really feels like the worst fucking podcast ever.
I got like the fucking hiccups,
you know?
I don't even know where the fuck I'm at.
This God damn thing.
But you know what I do know?
Pump up a Butoh dude.
Okay.
Get it to did it a bait if big,
big,
Big Bay Bay,
Bay Bay.
It's fucking football season.
Who Do you like tonight?
Between the Carolina Panthers and the Denver Broncos?
Well,
I'll tell you right now,
these Denver Broncos that beat these Carolina Panthers are not the same Denver
Bronco team that you saw this past January.
Obviously it doesn't need to be said,
but we're going to say it anyways.
Peyton manning rode off into the sunset.
The van is retired.
He will not be understand her screaming Omaha.
So I guess the Games probably in Denver,
I would think.
Right?
Is it in Denver?
I Dunno.
Bill.
Why don't you go to nfl.com and fucking figure it out.
Okay.
Why it is in fact,
in Denver,
I think Carolina wins this one,
right?
I'm going to give you all my fucking NFL picks right now,
not knowing shit about it.
Uh,
Carolina Beats Denver,
Tampa,
Atlanta.
Let's say Atlanta.
They're at home.
Matty ice.
They win that one.
Uh,
Buffalo Baltimore.
Baltimore is a great defense.
Uh,
I say Baltimore,
Chicago,
Houston.
Uh,
well that's a weird one.
You know,
it's kind of a pick up.
I'm just going to say Chicago cause I just,
I just picked two home teams in a row.
That's the level of fucking thought that I'm putting into this green papers.
Jacksonville.
What Green Bay is going to win that one?
Jesus Christ.
It's not even fair.
San Diego versus Kansas City.
I'm going to go with the man with a million children in picked San Diego,
right?
What's his,
I forget everybody's name.
The second the season ends,
it's a guy's fucking name.
He's got like nine kids.
Oh,
what's his fucking name?
What is his name?
Not Andrew Luck.
Not Eli Manning.
Not Tie Rod Taylor.
Not Derek Carr.
Not Matthew Stepford fell up.
Revers I'm going to go with the man.
You know the man with the Golden Gun.
This is the man with a million kids.
He's like real life.
The fucking Walton's.
You know?
And if you're going to have nine kids,
you might as well be a fucking multimillionaire.
Can you imagine what Christmas must be at their house?
Like how many fucking trees they have?
It's gotta be insane.
He probably buys all these sick ass fucking gifts,
you know what I mean?
If I had nine fucking kids and I had his money,
I buy them all like electric cars and I'd make them,
you know those little toy cars that you could sit in,
a little kid could sit and I make them race themselves around the fucking thing.
I'd have one of those circular driveways,
right?
I'd have time trials on Saturday.
I put them all on the super soft,
so on Sunday,
and I'd let him just fucking whip around and whoever won got dessert,
they ain't got to hang with me.
And then the rest of them would be banished to the loser wing of my mansion
and sure they would resent me.
A lot of them would cry,
especially the little ones,
you know?
But there'd be no excuses.
Cubs Sunday,
even if you were a baby,
you know,
if you couldn't figure out how to just roll down onto the gas pedal,
at least make a fucking effort slam into somebody,
then that would be at,
you would be banished by wife,
didn't like it.
She would be banished to.
Right.
This is why God never let me be a fucking
NFL quarterback.
That's,
that's exactly what I would do if I had nine fucking kids.
Jesus Christ.
I give every one of them would have like chores and I would never have shit to
do.
Do you have nine kids?
You can actually run a farm.
So if you just live in a fucking house,
you know what I mean?
I give each one of them are room.
You clean up to study.
That's your job,
right?
You don't clean up to study.
I'm taking away your car.
You're going to get,
you going to get punished.
A couple of grid grid positions come Sunday.
You're never going to have fucking dessert again.
You'd have to be strict with nine kids,
I would think.
Right?
Jesus Christ.
How many belts would you have to go through during your fucking,
the course of your,
uh,
you know,
or if he,
that dude from the Viking,
like how many fucking weeds of switches would you be pulling out of the ground?
I'm kind of a fucking lunatic.
Hits his own son and the nuts with a switch.
You know what I mean?
I get it.
That's the way you were brought up,
but you know,
you usually try to correct shit with your parents.
You know,
at some point you'd be like,
you know,
I'm going to stop short of hitting my own son in his little fucking pre
pubescent ball sack with a fucking switch.
You would like to think that someone would would make that leap,
but you know,
not everybody,
not everybody is as enlightened as me.
I like giving people advice that have children and I don't have any,
you know what I mean?
If you had nine kids,
you could actually,
you could even if nobody had any musical ability ability,
if you've sent all nine of them to American idol,
you got to think one of them would at least make it to Vegas,
right?
Someone was just have be able to carry your fucking tune.
Jesus Christ.
That's a giant God damn table.
Five kids on one side,
four on the other.
Your wife on one side,
you on the other.
I mean,
how many fucking Turkeys is that?
It's a lot of Goddamn kids.
That's fucking not,
that's like turn of the last century level kids.
You know what I mean?
They would just have nine cause you knew someone was getting diet polio,
somebody was going to get tuberculosis,
right.
Someone was going to fall down a fucking well and right there you're down to
six.
You know it starts getting nervous.
So I mean those crops,
you know the harvest is coming in and went down to six fucking kids.
You know,
your wife's just laying on her back making fucking bread with one hand,
churn the butter with the other and you just,
at the end of the day you come in and you just fucking walk right between the
legs like you do when you're behind the heard of oxen.
He just fucking put another one in her
dude.
You know,
you'd be like,
you're like a college coach,
college basketball coach.
It's like coaching Kentucky at that point.
The way the kids would leave you,
you know,
Kentucky,
they're like one and done all the good players.
So like you constantly got to be fucking out their prime when the pump throwing
the dollar bills around,
handing out Gold Trans Ams.
Right.
But back in the day,
rather than leaving and going to the pros,
they were just dying.
You know what I mean?
The more they died,
the more farmland they took up me.
Granted,
they were enriching the soil.
It their bodies decouple.
The buddies would decompose back then.
Right,
but they still put them in the boxes.
But you couldn't plant over there.
You know what I mean?
Oh my God.
I mean this color flour for some reason I'm thinking about addie.
Oh,
it's interesting you say that,
honey.
Cause I,
that's right where I fucking buried him.
Yeah.
The native Americans decided to do a drive by
and he took a fucking hatchet to the head.
I told him to duck.
He didn't.
He was weak.
He doesn't deserve to live.
All right,
there you go.
Now you're down to five kids.
I'm going to Google this right now.
Ways to die in 1900 let's see what comes up.
Ways to die.
I didn't finish my NFL picks.
Uh,
let's see here.
All right,
so I stopped off at Philip Rivers,
you know,
I gotta say the man with a thousand kids.
He's gonna win that one.
Oklahoma,
New Orleans at home got to go with New Orleans.
Cincinnati,
New Jersey.
I say New Jersey.
I mean I'd New Jersey,
New York jets.
I say they set the tone with a big loss against Seattle at home.
Cleveland.
Philly.
Do I even need to say it?
Philly wins that.
Minnesota,
Tennessee.
Oh,
the old fucking pre pubescent ball wipers.
You know what I'm going to say?
They're going to get a road when,
I dunno.
Why Miami?
Seattle.
That one's over before it begins at Seattle's Day.
A New York giants.
Cowboys.
Cowboys at all.
No.
Eli plays go to the road.
Eli Wins that one.
Detroit,
Indiana.
Uh,
what's that?
The pacers thoughts.
Andrew Luck.
I don't fucking know.
You know what?
Fuck it.
I'll say Detroit.
Detroit is going to cover doing Glen Arizona.
Oh,
what Jeanine Graf low under center.
I say the Patriots.
Surprise him.
No,
that's got to be a tough game.
We're going to,
Oh fuck that.
We're going to win Bill Bella checks going to figure him out.
He'll figure out a fucking white and then a win and then everybody will get sad
and then they'll start,
they'll start measuring Jimmy Garrett fellows,
whatever his fucking name,
they're going to measure his shoe strings.
And you know,
if you know that plastic tip,
if it had come undone for some reason,
that'll be so fucking,
you know,
four game suspension for him too.
And then we'll have,
uh,
you know,
our quarterback will also be a potter.
You know,
John Elway,
the older he gets,
the more he looks like he was one of the founding fathers.
He is a very,
like,
he looks like he signed something,
something that was on a scroll,
not when he wears sunglasses though the wrap around.
Good.
All right.
Good luck for him.
Um,
he definitely looks like he should be on money is his head should be on money or
maybe change.
Um,
alright.
Pittsburgh,
Washington.
Oh boy.
Uh,
he gotta go Pittsburgh,
Washington can't get out of their own fuck away then the La Rams.
I love it.
I love that.
That back against the San Francisco 40 niners.
I got to go 40 niners at home.
Even with the incredible distraction.
Can you believe that shit?
One guy sits down for the fucking national anthem.
What'd you even know?
He was doing it.
If they didn't tell you how much people are flipping out about that,
it's just fucking hilarious to me.
How does it affect your life?
I don't.
I don't care.
You don't care if he eats a fudgsicle Durden and if that's what the fuck he
wants to do,
God bless them.
Everybody acting like when they're at home.
This standing at attention.
When the fucking song comes on.
Think about some of this shit that you've been doing well and the rockets.
Red Glare.
You know
you fucking cleaning up dog shit or something with your hat on Jesus Christ kind
of American.
Are you all right ways to die in 1900
wasn't this a six sitcom?
It was a short list.
CITCO right?
Odd,
right after eight ways to fuck your mother.
Whatever the fuck.
Whatever the fuck it's called.
Um,
all right.
Ways to die.
Yeah.
How are we died 200 years ago.
Leading causes of death in the U S in 1900.
All right.
This is how your kids died.
If he had no,
this is why he had to have nine kids back in the day.
All right.
Influenza pneumonia.
See Ya.
That goes a good two,
three kids,
tuberculosis.
I called that.
This is like the Morbid family feud.
Gastrointestinal infections,
heart disease,
and then see she broke vascular disease.
One of the fuck then is what about farming equipment?
By 1950 was heart disease.
Oh No.
This,
this isn't kids though.
I got to put that,
I got to say kids,
uh,
ways to die as a,
as a kid.
Jesus.
Fuck would sort of watch list.
This has put me on.
All right,
let me right.
Let me take this up.
Ways to die as a child in 1900 wold childbirth was one of them.
And you lost your wife.
That was like your Scout,
right?
Fuck.
Who's going to keep bringing in the new talent?
Um,
boys to die?
Trends.
Death.
This historical horror of childbirth.
All right.
Leading causes of death.
Uh,
you know what,
they're not going to have it.
Death in childbirth.
Okay,
whatever.
I'm still going with farming equipment.
You know,
dad's out on the team.
Oxen.
Go Tell Paul it's time for dinner,
right?
You go out there and the oxygen gets spooked or some shit and they run over.
You built.
We don't have know about fucking dead farm kits.
All right,
well you know,
fuck you want from me?
You know what?
Just for that.
Just for that,
you're going to get some advertising.
All right.
Oh,
gimme the Lou Lou,
Craig,
everybody.
Are you looking for gear,
collectibles,
housewares and more from your favorite pop culture franchises?
I know,
I'm not.
Uh,
this is for the nerds.
Here we go.
You there.
Where are the underoos?
You dress like a,
the hulk.
Here we go.
We've got you covered.
Loot crate offers a range of Geek and Gamer items for less than $20 a month.
Want to bring your loot to the next level?
Get a bigger box.
Even with bigger loop with loot crate DX.
If you're more the type to where your geeky heart on your sleeve and Lou,
where our monthly wearables and accessory subscriptions is what you're looking
for.
Have they even fucking said what they are yet?
I still don't get what this shit is.
Get ready for September is high octane theme speed.
What are you gonna get a tee shirt with Sandra Bullock on the front?
We got to stop the boat.
This month's Lou crate has a high octane assortment of goodies from Batman,
CWS,
the flash and Arrow Batman.
It's not fast ms fucking cars.
Fat.
He was kind of fat,
wasn't he?
At least the one on TV was Battlestar Galactica iron man and gone 60 seconds.
Well,
there's a left turn.
You go from all of those to fucking Nicolas Cage.
Um,
if you need.
Okay
bunches,
fucking superhero.
Superman,
Batman,
Nicolas Cage.
You know that shit.
Um,
if you,
if you have a style need,
you'll love our speed loot.
Where collection featuring sonic socks for when you got to go fast.
A train off.
Can't imagine the fatties fucking wearing those things.
A transformers wearable for your world.
Saving needs a winning Mario Kart,
t and more.
Does anybody knows what any of this is?
This loop where collection is going to zoom away,
quick.
Transformable,
wearable.
Those are the things that our cars and then there were robots you have until the
19th at 9:00 PM Pacific.
Just subscribe and received that month's crate and then the cutoff happens.
That's it.
It's over.
Just like your social.
Yeah.
Make sure they had the ww dot [inaudible] dot com slash burr and enter burr to
save $3 off any subscription.
All right.
Is this the last one?
I don't feel like doing this.
Okay.
Oh,
legal zoom,
everybody.
Legal Zoom.
How are you?
God bless you.
You've heard the expression time is money,
right?
Right.
Well,
it's true.
Evidently,
especially when you run a business,
she can't afford to waste time taking care of your legal needs.
Somebody does a face plant.
You can't figure out what their medical condition is.
You need to fucking step over them and keep moving up that hill.
That's why he should lose.
Use a legal zoom.
If you work with the typical attorney,
they'll charge you.
I just pictured some fucking hack with a little pocket watch trying to be
original.
It's like you're a fucking hack.
Well what?
What do you,
what do you put the fuck?
Do you work out parking tickets?
Do you work with a typical attorney?
They'll charge you for their time.
It's called the billable hour and a lot of times they won't tell you how much,
how long it'll take in advance,
but legal zoom is different.
They're not a law firm.
They've spent the last 15 years making sure you get the most out of your time by
building a usable website paired with amazing customer service support for
efficient help and if you need advice,
legal zoom works with independent attorneys.
Licensed in 48 states are attorneys who are more focused on helping you,
the logging billable hours.
That's why millions of people have trusted legal,
so you can expect quality legal help on your schedule and flat fees instead of
expensive hourly rates.
Invest your time and money in your business and use legal zoom for legal stuff
and save even more by entering bird and the referral box at checkout.
That's legalzoom.com a fuck this one more.
He looks everybody Hallux.
You're unique.
No,
you're not.
You're fucking in the crowd.
Stop fucking butter and these people up because you don't like you.
Don't walk like everyone else.
Okay?
Agreed.
Talk like everyone else.
Agreed or sleep like everyone else.
You know what Alex Helix.
I owe you an apology.
I guess I am unique.
So why is your mattress one size fits all well,
because it's too expensive to have a customized mattress,
isn't it?
Because they truly customized mattress will cost you five to 10,000 bucks until
now I'll do what I called it.
It's almost like I've read this copy before.
Go to [inaudible] dot com how likes sleep.com answer a few simple questions.
What's your favorite color?
What are you thinking?
Do you like apples?
And they'll run a three d biochemical model of your body through the proprietary
algorithms they've developed with the help.
Big words with the help of the world's leading era.
Go non-mec in biochem act takes experts.
The result,
the most comfortable mattress you've ever slept on.
Helux customers report at 30% improvement in overall sleep quality.
And for couples,
they customize each side of the bed.
You fucking freaks.
I want to swing over mine.
Okay.
Your mattress arrives at your door in about a week and shipping is 100% free.
That's why everyone from Gq magazine to Forbes are all talking about headaches.
Sleep.
You'll,
you'll have a hundred nights to try it out.
If you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for free,
gross and give you 100% refund.
No questions asked.
Well,
I hope they use rubber gloves.
Go to helix,
sleep.com/burr and get $50 off your order.
That's Heloc sleep.com/.
Bar.
Hey,
he looks sleek.com/.
Birth.
All right,
there you go.
That's the fucking Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
checking in on your podcast.
Enjoy this music and uh,
some clips from a podcast from a fucking week gone by.
I don't know.
No.
Um,
sleep,
walk,
banging a Billy boy.
I need some advice for something I can guarantee you haven't gotten an email
about before.
This one is personal.
It's not really,
what do you hyping,
you're fucking God damn thing.
Just get to it.
All right.
Over the last year I have discovered that I engage in sleepwalking behavior.
The most hilarious part of it.
I think fucking Mike Birbiglia wrote a whole one man show that's now a movie
about this.
So I really don't think you're breaking new ground,
although I'll give you the,
I'll give you the benefit of the doubt.
The most hilarious part of it is that I engage in sleep sex.
Okay.
You know what?
Go Fuck Yourself.
Do you think I'm dumb enough to believe this?
You're either just making this shit up or you're a fucking pervert and you're
going around basically sexually assaulting other people and then say,
ah,
I was asleep.
Sorry that I put my dick on your lip.
Oh my fault.
I was sleeping.
Um,
anyways,
let,
let's,
let's just,
you know,
to fill up the hour.
I'm going to read the rest of this,
but I'm already calling bullshit cause I've been with my girlfriend for four
years now and we're both 22 years old.
We share a room in a house together with other housemates and let me guess,
you wander in and accidentally fucked somebody else.
Is that what you gonna tell me?
Is that really where this fucking email is going to go?
Um,
I've found out that if we don't have sex at least once every two days,
I will basically begin to perform sex acts on her while I sleep.
Dude,
you are so full of fucking shit.
Okay.
I will have absolutely no memories of these.
Here's his out.
Oh,
did I fucking finger bang you with my Dick in your ass.
Sorry.
I was sleep.
Sleep's automizing.
Um,
I will have no memories,
memories of these in the morning unless I wake up during the act.
My girlfriend says that my eyes are open,
but totally glazed over when I do it.
The most common one is that I will go down on her.
This is so fucking stupid.
You're asleep,
you're asleep and you're dreaming,
right?
Your eyes are open,
but you're,
you're still like in rem sleep and you're somehow pulling the covers off.
Fine.
What are you a fucking Zombie?
I,
you know,
I'm not reading the rest of this.
This is the most ridiculous fucking die,
but you know what,
maybe this people interested,
I'll keep reading.
This is the dumbest thing that sounds like a Scott bail movie from the
[inaudible].
Liz was this the original draft of zapped?
Um,
somebody 43 years old,
just fucking did a spit take on the dashboard with that reference.
Um,
what the hell am I?
Yeah.
I have also fingered her as well.
Stupidest thing.
The one that I am least proud of is that I apparently licked my own TJ's offer
boobs after all,
after coming
capital letters all in my sleep.
Dude is the most
bizarre fucking thing I've ever read.
Okay.
My girlfriend is actually really cool.
Hey,
you asleep and it's fine honey.
Go like this.
No,
on the other side.
Yeah.
You got a little more,
are there,
uh,
at this,
at first she'll be really startled because she is sleeping too.
If I'm going down are in my sleep,
she generally,
let's keep going until she comes.
I'll usually wake up as she's coming.
We'll have sex and we'll both go back to sleep.
Oh,
Jesus Christ the,
I swear to God people.
There's two more paragraphs of this shit.
Do you want me to keep going?
The scary part to me is the fear of not having control over my body and my
actions.
I'm scared because I have clearly shown my ability to perform complete tasks
while being completely asleep and having absolutely no memory of them later.
I'm afraid that one day I'll find myself waking up,
driving my car down the highway.
I haven't shown myself doing anything dangerous yet.
You haven't shown my,
you haven't found yourself,
but who knows,
right.
The only reason I do know about the times it has happened so far is because my
girlfriend has been there to tell me it happened.
Who knows what crazy shit I've done before I met her in my sleep that I'll never
know about.
My girlfriend says,
I'm just being paranoid and then I should let it be.
Wait a minute,
you fucking came on your girlfriend's tits,
licked your own jazz off of him and she's like,
Oh,
you're just big paranoid.
Is this the white chick from every fucking horror movie?
Um,
I don't think that noise is anything to be concerned about.
what would you do?
Would you go see a therapist or a doctor for this?
So would you just let it go?
I really don't.
Don't,
yeah,
this is beyond,
he goes,
I really don't want to be,
go to a doctor with a bunch of pills.
You know what I would email Mike Birbiglia.
I actually think I vaguely remember him talking about walking over to a window
or something,
you know,
and doing something.
I can't remember.
You know,
I don't,
I don't remember.
I would email him.
Oh,
why don't,
yeah.
Why don't you fuck what?
Yeah.
Go to another comedian now.
Fuck that.
Go.
Go talk to a professional.
All right.
Jesus Christ.
If that's,
if that's real.
Is it real son?
Is it really real son?
Um,
that's one of the big things in hip hop.
Everybody's got it.
Yo,
this is real shot.
This rail.
This is like the cities where it's like,
dude,
it's all real me laying on a bed right now doing a podcast in Jacksonville.
That's also real.
Everything's real son.
All right.
Last week,
last week,
I was laughing my ass off reading this thing where this guy was trying to claim
mmm.
That,
that sleep,
sex shit.
You know,
basically he's asleep and he just starts having sex with his fucking,
yeah,
a girlfriend
and he's completely asleep.
He's totally asleep.
I just,
evidently this is somebody says,
hey bill,
this does exist.
This does happen to me at least a dozen times a year.
That's what somebody wrote in.
MMM.
Listen to this one.
It bill,
I feel compelled to write to you this email after hearing the Monday morning
podcast this morning.
I know the guys sleep sex story sounds insane,
but I can tell you that it's a 100% a real thing.
Hear me out.
This is so fucking nuts.
Somebody else told me that there was somebody,
okay.
Who fucking was asleep,
woke up,
didn't wake up,
got up like a fucking Zombie,
got in the car,
drove across town,
murdered somebody and came back and got off because they were asleep.
Okay.
You can't drive a car when you're fucking asleep.
This is bullshit.
I don't,
I don't give a fuck if there's a scientific name for that.
Are Your eyes open then you were awake?
Well,
you're driving down the street with,
would you fucking eyes closed?
You know,
are these these people like supernatural being that a witches,
what are they doing?
Why are they having sex?
Why don't they wake up and do like fucking a,
they start,
you know,
scrubbing the floor.
Why do they always go do something fun?
Okay.
Like get laid or kill somebody that's annoying them.
How come they never do anything miserable?
Oh my God,
I got fucking,
you know I was,
I've reached shingled the roof for my neighbor.
Yeah,
it's just bullshit.
It's just fucking bullshit.
Fuck all you guys.
I'll read it.
I'll try to have an open mind.
Here's another guy who suffers from a getting laid while he's sleeping in
college.
I was dating a girl who would do the same thing.
I started spending the night at her place,
which was closer to campus than my dorm.
One night I came back really late after driving back to college from home.
I walked in.
I heard a loud moaning like someone was having sex thinking see was sheeting.
I'll be a bus into room to beat the shit out of whoever's she was fucking,
which is hilarious.
Why would you beat the shit out of that person unless they knew you and knew
that you were in a relationship.
The guys just doing what he's supposed to be doing.
He's trying to get laid.
You should go in there and fucking call the girl a whore and then leave miss
direct that anger.
Anyways,
he goes,
I walked in only to find her by herself in bed naked from the waist down.
Fingering the hell out of herself.
Yeah.
So he goes,
so I walked over thinking I could get in on the action.
Okay.
And her eyes were closed and she wouldn't respond to me talking to her dude.
What kind of fucking Blair witch?
Uh,
the extra assistance is fucking creepy.
You walk in or eyes are closed.
He's like in a Zombie state finger blast in herself.
And your first thought is,
hey,
maybe I can get in on the action.
That right there just shows the weakness of a man.
The fact that he can go from that level of rage.
I would've beat the fuck out whoever,
whoever's bagging my girl to two seconds later,
like,
hey,
maybe I can help you out with that layer.
A little lady.
Uh,
anyways,
once she finished,
she seemed to fall asleep immediately thinking this was crazy.
I woke her up and asked her what the fuck was going on.
She admitted that this happens sometimes,
not very often,
but sometimes.
And she never told me about it because it was embarrassing.
I was like,
okay,
whatever.
It never really thought about it again.
Really.
You saw something that bizarre.
We're like,
hi.
Okay.
You know,
then he never thought about it again.
That sounds like that would be like so disturbing to see somebody in a Zombie
fight state fingering themselves.
I don't think,
I mean just me picturing what that looks like.
I don't know if I'll ever be able to forget it.
Um,
anyway,
now let me get to a fuck.
I'm gonna Sneeze.
God dammit.
Hang on a second.
Okay.
All right.
I'm back.
I'm back here.
Um,
yeah,
like I don't think I could ever get that thought out of my head.
Oh.
I just kind of shook it off and continued on and he said,
now let's get to where I say sleep.
Sex is real.
About three weeks later I was spending the night at her place again and I woke
up to her talking in her sleep.
Oh my God,
dude,
this is the creepy as shit if she's speaking in tongues.
Okay.
Six,
six,
600 fucking forearm.
This sounds like one of those.
The uh,
ah,
I got it all can name of the fucking movie is.
Uh,
anyways.
What the hell was I?
Did we say that I woke up,
she was talking her asleep but talking like she was having sex saying shit like
fuck me and stuff.
But she was just talking,
not doing anything else.
So she's sitting up in bed.
Yeah,
having a fucking conversation or eyes fucking dot.
Oh,
like rolling around in a fucking head.
This is a creepy as shit ever.
Do you guys sleep in like a pyramid?
Is she like,
like she like fucking cursed.
This sounds like some shit that would only happen like in an Indiana Jones
movie.
MMM.
So he goes,
so I decided to wake her up or let her know what she was doing.
I leaned over and kind of shook her softly,
you know,
saying,
Hey,
wake up.
Wake up.
Instead of waking up,
she rolled toward me
the Zombie.
Ah.
Fuck man.
That's the fucking exercise.
Yeah.
Saki.
Dag.
Ah.
Um,
oh God.
I always forget that I'm in New York.
I can't imagine what my fucking
fucking neighbors are thinking right now.
Instead of waking up,
she rolled toward me.
Yeah.
They put her hands down my pants and started jerking me off and kissing me.
See,
this is where it goes out the window.
Okay.
This is where it goes out.
It's a jerky.
Oh Dude.
This is where it goes out the fucking window for me.
If you're asleep,
how do you know where the where everything is?
Okay.
Oh,
I'm asleep and I'm walking up to the garage,
not bumping into anything.
Grabbing the keys.
I gotta go kill that neighbor.
Give me a fucking break.
This is the dumbest Shit I've ever heard in my life.
This isn't real.
So she wrote,
source has jerking me off,
kissing me,
and then still in her,
in her sleep said,
are you going to fuck the or what?
And he goes,
well shit.
How can I turn that down?
How could you turn it down?
Because your fucking eyes are rolling up in her head.
Dude.
Isn't this like a form of rape?
Okay.
If she's asleep and your bag and her,
I mean that's just what if,
what if you didn't know her?
She walks up and back me back bay,
walking around fucking pajamas out in the lawn,
pulled up in a car.
This is the creepiest Shit I've ever read about.
Am I in my five years of doing this podcast,
this is the creepiest shit ever.
This is Linda Blair.
Linda Blair is a porn star.
So she goes,
you're going to fuck me?
Or what if the guy goes,
well,
shit,
how can I turn that down?
I started to take my pants off and her still sleeping.
Started stripping in the bed.
See this?
This all has like a,
I'm awake kind of thing or possessed one or the other.
He goes,
we started going at it,
but the whole time her eyes were still closed,
but it was like she was awake,
grabbing onto me,
kissing me moaning.
It was totally crazy.
Then the craziest thing,
so this girl was one of those more reserve types.
We never really had dirty sex suit.
If you bang this girl in the ass while she's fucking in this zombified state,
um,
I,
I don't know what to tell you.
Okay.
He goes,
we never really had dirty sex or anything.
It was still really good,
but nothing out of the ordinary except tonight.
All of a sudden,
okay,
while we're going at it,
she flips over onto her knees and says,
put it in my ass.
Like,
God,
dude,
fuck you guys.
Did you guys all get together and just say,
let's fuck with bill and let's just write the craziest fucking emails.
Average.
Is there some sort of website where you guys are doing this?
I,
this is not real.
This isn't real.
He goes,
what the fuck?
I above fucking fell over.
Never had we even talked about it or anything,
and all of a sudden she was doing things she had never done,
at least with me,
without even seeming like it was new.
She just acted like it happens all the fucking time.
Dude,
if you do this,
okay,
why don't you wake her up?
It'd be like,
sweetheart,
just to let you know that you were asleep right now telling me to put my dick in
your ass.
I,
you know,
are you comfortable with going back to sleep and letting me do that?
I'm just checking.
Alright.
Nighty night.
Um,
anyways,
it was one of the craziest nights of sex I ever had.
Dude,
you're a fucking creep.
You're a fucking creep dude.
You're a fucking creep.
Okay.
If I was with somebody and they were a Zombie,
I would wake them up.
All right.
You had fucking anal sex with this girl when she was like awake,
asleep,
awake,
whatever the fuck they did.
The medical version of this is fucking insane.
Uh,
the next morning she woke up and didn't mention a thing about it at all it all
day.
So I finally decided to bring it up.
Oh,
that's a good move.
Hey,
by the way,
last night when you were sleeping,
but kind of we're awake but we're asleep.
Ah,
I,
I put it in your ass if you wondered why Ya,
you know,
you felt a little weird this morning.
Yeah.
Cause I have Jesus.
He goes,
I told her what happened and at first she was pretty pissed.
Yeah,
I would think so.
But then after talking about it for a few minutes,
she admitted that this had happened a few times before where she said sex in
asleep with someone,
including her sister's boyfriend.
Wow.
That's what he wrote.
And I would've said that anyways.
Do,
so the boyfriend banged once she was sleeping or sister's boyfriend's at that
this is like rape guys.
Yeah.
This is fucking nuts.
She's not in a place where she can say no,
she's dreaming about something else.
If this shit even exists is the creepiest fucking email ever.
Oh,
when it keeps going,
she started crying and saying she didn't know what to do.
So I offered to go with her to a therapist and at least approached the topic
with the professional or aren't you just a fucking great guy after you banged
her in the ass while she was sleeping,
the therapist said she may have sexsomnia.
That was the term she used.
Seriously,
look it up.
Or a sleep disorder where a person actually has sex in their sleep.
Yeah,
go,
fuck you sexsomnia that now.
Now,
fuck you.
I'm not,
I'm not buying this.
Yeah.
The therapist said it's more common than people think.
No,
it isn't.
None of my friends to have this story.
They would have told me,
and that is treatable only in some cases she got on some medication.
It seemed to help a little,
but there were a few times when shit happened in her sleep and no,
those times I did not bang her in her sleep after that one time.
It's just didn't feel right since it was something she had no control over.
Really.
It took you after that first time,
so instead I would wake her up.
That's what you should have done the first time.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Anyways,
just wanted to send you this email so he didn't think the sleep sex guy was a
total psycho.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I downloaded your latest special love that catch you later.
Well,
thank you for downloading this special.
Uh,
as far as your,
uh,
yeah,
chivalrous acts after you fucking went anal on that girl.
I don't know about that man.
Wow.
Well there you go.
People.
That was worth the price of admission,
Huh?
I still don't believe it.
Sexsomnia
at the very least.
It's not common.
I W I would have heard something about it.
Okay.
I'm down.
Like I'm acting like I'm a doctor right now.
I am down,
I am in the medical field.
I'm up to my knees and it,
I would have heard something.
I would have heard some sort of study by and I don't know.
Right.
A professor wants to bank,
hey bill,
I'm a 19 year old male college freshmen and my professor wants to have sex.
I'm sorry that wasn't me.
That was somebody else yelling,
okay,
I'm going to be a professional.
I kept getting these signs ever since the first few weeks of class began.
You're 19,
you're an adult,
right.
And I'm not really,
I can't get in trouble here.
Right.
Um,
I noticed anytime I am running late to class by a few minutes,
she would always wait for me to start class
through get to the good part.
What does she look like?
Every time I walked in and she would say things like,
oh,
I was worried you were sick and I was worried you were going to miss my class.
Jesus.
She's putting it out there right in front of the whole class.
Um,
anytime any l anyone else's late to class,
she ignores them and starts on time.
Well,
wait a minute to it.
Or you're the teacher's pet,
you know,
when she says sal,
did everybody do the reading last night?
Do we have any,
any thoughts on the,
um,
the assigned material?
Everyone just sits there staring at her,
chewing their gum slowly.
And you actually put your,
your,
your hand up.
Oh,
Michael,
what do you have to say?
I found it.
I thought it was brave.
I thought it was,
it was exquisite,
you know?
All right.
Let me wanting to just read the rest of us here.
Um,
anytime.
Anyone else's late to class,
she ignores them.
Starts on time.
Okay.
She is always over the top.
Nice to me when we see each other.
I brushed this off and I didn't let it get big in my head.
All right.
So He's,
he's,
he's like,
he's not thinking that this is going to happen.
Okay.
A telltale sign came to me one day when I was small.
I was at the smoking section on the campus after I left her class,
I cheated word for word from the girl that sits next to me in class on a test I
had just finished.
The girl that sits next to me came down to the smoking section with the bag of
chocolate in her hand and gave it to me.
She told me our professor gave it to her to give to me.
Yeah.
Boy,
they're trying to bang.
Your teacher is like trying to get away with a murder.
The more people who are involved,
the bigger chance you have of getting caught.
So what the fuck is she'd given this girl chalk the for bringing her in the
fall.
Fox.
She wants a threesome,
right?
Is this,
where is this where it's going?
Please tell me it's going in this direction.
This is like a red shoe diaries.
Um,
I asked the girl if our professor gave the chocolate to the class when I left
and she said,
no,
I tried to keep calm
that you would say as my Dick was filling up,
I try to keep calm and asked the girl how she did on the test.
Um,
I told her I copied her word for word and she said she thinks she did.
A few minutes later,
our professor came down to the smoking section where her car was parked.
The girl asked the professor what,
what she made.
And the professor tells us she made a 74.
When I asked her,
she flipped her hair,
smirked at me and told me I made a 94.
Wow.
Okay.
I'm going to tell you right now.
Right fucking now if this happens,
dude,
you were two condoms.
This woman is reckless.
Okay.
Go ahead and bang.
You're fucking teacher to do it towards the end of the semester.
So bad.
Anyways,
she's 36 years old and divorced.
MMM.
On this certain website.
Wherever Denley people can uh,
basically rate their teachers.
The students rated her as hot.
I want to ask her out to lunch sometime.
Dope.
She's 36.
Just fucker.
She didn't want to go to lunch.
She's 36.
She wants lunch.
She'll buy our own lunch.
But that's,
you know,
you're 19.
I keep forgetting it.
Anyways,
the only reason why I haven't asked her out yet is because she told me she has a
13 year old daughter.
We or
oh,
okay.
That's the sound of her vagina.
She already had a kid.
[inaudible] Oh,
uh,
Mike,
my question to you is,
would it be wrong?
There are other girls I have met,
but they are the typical dumb whores you find in college.
Okay.
All of them.
Yeah.
I wouldn't think every girl is a dumb whore.
Is every guy a dumb jock.
Does every jog dumb?
See what happens when we talk in absolutes.
Um,
I am not saying I want to marry this broad,
just a one night stand with the history.
The professor would be nice.
I am not the type of guy that likes to go around and fuck as many girls as I
made.
That is why I keep thinking that she has,
that she has a daughter and I should probably stay away.
What do you think?
MMM.
I don't know dude.
The fact that you hit yet did you don't want to fucking do what I,
I don't know.
Well listen,
do you know how to bang a girl and then fucking see you the next day and have it
all be cool that that's a skill,
you know,
and not have her feel like you used her or whatever,
you know?
Do you know how to do that?
Hmm.
I can tell you one thing you don't want to do is,
what I would do was,
was the next day I'd be like,
Hey,
I'll fucking weird.
And then they get mad and the next thing you know,
all of their friends are fucking looking at you like you're a Dosha and they
start drawn right and shit on your locker.
US A fucking nightmare.
Um,
yeah.
If you've mastered the Yarra,
how to somebody and not be a,
yeah,
I don't,
you know something dude.
If you're going to fuck this girl,
you have to do it at the end of the semester.
Once it's over.
Um,
this girl,
she's reckless.
She's a nightmare.
If she's fucking putting this out,
it's unbelievably unprofessional.
She should be way more discreet.
Alright?
And you cheated on this girl word for word she gave you 20 points are,
you know what dude?
Stay away from this girl.
This girl is,
is she's going to get fucking pregnant and you don't want it to be you.
All right.
Who doesn't want to fuck a teacher?
Everybody does,
but she knows something.
You don't want to have a fucking eat it.
I wouldn't do it.
Don't do it.
Stay away.
Why don't you go meet some nice girls to stop talking to dumb horse and,
uh,
you know,
I dunno.
Rub One out before you go to class and really thinking,
bought it in the morning.
You know,
what happened.
Okay.
All right.